we've all seen how the culture politics
has gone off the rails but is there hope
or at least some comedy in the cart
let's ask Rob Schneider from woke up in
America on Fox Nation Rob great to see
you now we learned this week that
Commander Joe Biden's dog is a biting
addict now we're up to at least a dozen
incidents now and you heard of that one
bite rule with dogs well it's you know
Biden it's means it's inflation so now
it's a 12 by rule as they continue to
work through solution Commander is not
presently at the White House on on the
White House campus and while next while
while next steps are evaluated back on
Commander where exactly is Commander the
dog right now is he in Wilmington I'm
not going to go beyond saying that he's
noer Rob they won't even tell us where
the dog is Laura thank you for having me
on to talk about the these important
issues U Commander first of all the
Biden Administration I think acted de
decisively they didn't wait till the
13th person got bit after 12 they said
enough and they killed two birds with
one stone because I just found out that
Commander the dog is now at the border
biting immigrants trying to sneak over
so that's two birds with one stone
that's decisive he's right down there
right now or or he's living next to
James comr or something or strike right
before the next hearing on Hunter Biden
all right Rob speak you got to give you
got to give the Biden the Biden
Administration you got to give them
though because the same thing how
decisively he worked on the border he
didn't wait 3 years to start putting up
a new fence he waited two years and nine
months that's decisive he did and by the
way for everyone saying it's racist uh
the Democrats relax this this new uh
fence is only going to be two feet high
so just relax they'll still be able to
come over no and by the way I don't know
if you just know that they they they
took down the sign today you know the
sign first Biden sign the first 10
million get in free they change it every
like McDonald's wasn't it cool when you
were a kid they kept changing it like
five billion Burgers sold yes well this
one was in Spanish so is Los
Primos Gratis so they they took that
down oh I actually work that on my
Spanish all right Rob speaking of the
border now local Democrat leaders are
taking trips down there watch just
landed in uh City trying to be on the
ground and understand you know the whole
flow of the migrant migrant and Asylum
Seekers wait Rob what's there to
understand there are millions of people
going through Mexico and walking right
into the other United States but mayor
Adams needs to leave New York which has
turned into a hellhole and go down there
to examine the
flow well Mexico City is not where it's
happening that's about 1,200 miles South
of the Border I would suggest he goes to
the actual border and sees what what's
happening but I think it's better
because the the restaurants in Mexico
City are Inc the the is excellente
theila so he's made a better choice the
the the the salsa dancing is much better
there than at the border so he'll have a
much better time good choice mayor now
moving to Capitol Hill Rob um earlier
this week Kevin McCarthy of course we
all know lost his job as Speaker Nancy
Pelosi lost cushy office that really
made one of your friends upset watch
gavl abuser Patrick McKenry immediately
evicted Pelosi from her offices in the
capital back on the Looney Tune side of
the capital former Democratic Majority
Leader stenny Hoyer was also evicted
from his office and guess who's moving
into Pelosi's old office Kevin
McCarthy Rob didn't they they voted to
remove Kevin McCarthy all the Democrats
all her Pals and now they're upset that
I there's some repercussions there
well I have to say that I thought the
Republicans treated Nancy Pelosi very
kindly because to make her feel at home
very California like on as they were
escorting out they line the hallway with
homeless people defecating which I
thought was very in Good Taste and then
her new office I don't know have you've
heard Laura have you seen the new office
she's ecstatic it's right next Nancy
Pelosi's new office is right next to the
botox bar she's psyched oh that you
don't have to walk for her it's it's
quite easy all right Rob turning to 2024
I know you're into this it looks like
we're going to have two third party
candidates running Cornell West ditching
the green party running as independent
then RFK Jr big announcement set for
next week what do we
know well I I hope first of all I I want
there to be at least two parties there's
just one party I mean it seems like the
Republicans now are just like Democrats
who don't give their kids puberty
blockers at this
point all right rob you are going to be
performing live at the uh Maryland
theater in Town Maryland tomorrow night
and I wish I was going to be there but I
can't be there but next time I will be
there thanks Rob hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else